on today's episode of lunch and earn I'm
going to talk about how you should
expect to suck at the start hello
believe nation I've talked a lot about
on this channel how when you're first
starting something you're going to suck
at it right any new skill that you
trying to pick up you're gonna suck
whether it's learning a language picking
up a new sport picking up a new skill
learning the video game trying to
understand marketing or counting
whatever it is you're trying to
understand you will suck at the start
and the story I've told a couple times
on these videos is looking back on my
channel look back on the old videos and
see the progress right 2500 videos later
you can see how I've grown I've gotten
better and I sucked at the start and
hopefully suck a little bit less and now
but one thing that time that struck me
as I was watching through my channel was
the end special series I started out a
couple months ago and the first one that
I did was of Dame Dash and it was a
selfish project for me because I wanted
something in the morning to kind of get
me excited getting inspired make me
think bigger but when I started it I
didn't have it all planned out and I
think this is something that's really
critical for a lot of you entrepreneurs
is you wanna not over plan and expect to
suck at the start and it's okay because
you're going to get better and better
and better and better so I want to show
a couple clips now from that first Dame
Dash and espresso if you're holding
yourself back from doing something that
you really want to do because other
people are telling you that it's not a
good idea I'm going to share with you a
clip from Dame Dash on how to not care
about what other people think this is a
great reminder that the bigger your idea
is the more you want to have a positive
impact the more what you're trying to do
is different and outside the box from
the normal standard life the more hate
you're going to get the more negativity
you're going to get and the more
discouragement you're going to get from
people saying don't do it so if you
notice I didn't have a name for it right
we didn't have an espresso I didn't
start off with high energy with my good
morning believe nation right I didn't
have anything fun like I normally do
with the start of an espresso whether
I'm jumping off the side of a Ledge or
climate
tree or stomping superheroes right I
didn't have anything fun that I normally
do I did it inside and it was kind of
boring I didn't have my camera man with
me helping me I didn't end it off with
the shot events presso right all of the
things that make express of what it is
now I didn't have when I started but I
discovered those things by doing by
trying and by improving each week and
making them better and better and better
and I wouldn't have been able to planet
without actually getting out and trying
it so you know that those first videos
suck in comparison to what I have now
and that's still even having thousands
of videos on my channel the first time I
try something I still suck at it and
still try to get better and better and
better and better and so the message is
don't be afraid to try something new and
expect to be amazing at it at the start
because you're going to suck that's
natural that's part of learning and
you'll get better and better and better
and and stop trying to have the perfect
plan because it doesn't exist and you'll
learn by actually trying and improving
along the way believed thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know from
you in the comments below what you suck
that at the start recently and what you
are working on and getting better and
better and better what you're trying to
improve yourself on I love to hear from
you leave a comment below thank you guys
so much for joining me for this episode
of lunch and earn I hope you enjoy your
lunch continue to believe and I'll see
you soon